squeeze aujourd'hui on se trouve sur the
wave est là non attendez nom mais qui
est en fait comme son nom l'indiqué un
jeu de course d'animaux voilà alors
j'aimerais bien savoir l'histoire dans
un premier temps fait le plus à savoir
s'est passé première course
alors on a le choix entre huit animaux
un cheval réunion cauchois j'aime bien
le cochon my son petit chapeau les
mignons ils ont des stats très bien bas
je prends le cochon même si les stats je
pose pas très bien il ya huit maps aussi
[ __ ] mais beaucoup de contenu d'enjeux
anas gates est partie difficulté médium
esquiver les obstacles trouver de la
nourriture pour avoir de l'énergie pour
gagner la course
je crains le pire quoi l'introduction
introduction un peu longue
d'accord ok carrément sa part comme ça
waouh c'est un début de course
incroyable des animaux pas du tout
naturel prennent leur élan sur la piste
à ça c'est nous c'est parti mr je
tombais touche [ __ ] pire départ des
courses du monde commence auto caisse
avec le clic gauche
qu'est ce qu'ils font mais qui défonce
tout mais c'est frau [ __ ] os montes
dessus de vence à sa coupe à des animaux
sauvages on peut mettre au contrôle et
en y avait des choix c'était de la
nourriture nathan mais ils sont trop
rapides ces gens mais je peux accélérer
regarder et c'est vraiment et ya pas la
nourriture à un [ __ ] y avait une glace
à la hâte en accrochant sa manche car
c'est lui qui l'a de la nourriture mais
oui mais ils achèteraient pas gentil
gros poupe mais c'est du caca d'oie zoos
mais c'est n'importe quoi
la meilleure musique de la planète c'est
maintenant c'est pour nous mais arrête
de me doubler [ __ ] c'est la victoire
c'est la victoire
oui il allait bien comme ça j'ai dit je
m'en sers victoire j'aimerais bien
savoir parce que si je suis mort la
chute un peu longue au wat
adacore c'est une grosse en deux étapes
très bien je vous ai mais ils s'en
foutent
ok c'était un saut tout pourri en fait
en le rhino il est carré manchot ou là
le cheval by un peu droite ou gauche
ok c'est à gauche le rhino l'avez
compris nickel qu'est ce que fait cette
femme au mieux de la course ça lui
allait aller faut foncer foncer job de
zulte constat du mot [ __ ] cessé de
nous attraper nous revendre arrête de
chanter qui change le macaque est celle
enregistrée sa copine sur ses sous la
douche course à ce nom c'est le mag
c'est le bug je ne finirai jamais la
course il s'envola vers le ciel est dit
au revoir à ses amis animaux on te prend
plus jamais monsieur piggy on va prend
le mouton amateurs faut dégager cette
musique là c'est juste pas possible
oh mon dieu ça fait tellement du bien ce
parti allaient quand je suis content
j'ai le haut et à la mascarade cork
petit tour de maps incroyable avant le
départ d'une course ou sur les animaux
ah on reconnaît la porte
allez on trace monga steak cookies
offrant tout ce qui pourrait le dire
pigeon je le vengerai c'est pas grave on
est pas mal là et derrière l'ipo est
plutôt la brasse et on peut le voir qui
sont ces genres blocage non ça marche
pas trop et c'est là rien non à chaque
fois je m'enflamme n'est pas du tout on
arrive on te rattrape
quoi
non non
donc
j'ai cédé c'est quoi cette connerie
c'est le grave accident effets spéciaux
waouh
jean des transformers est ce qu'on
pouvait écraser les autres alors je peux
pas m'empêcher je peux pas je suis
désolé d'accord et le tram disparaît
merci monsieur le 3 mai on attend mec je
suis en train carrément une double c'est
n'importe quoi non une double et
voiliers de steaks hachés
c'est l'arrivée c'est la victoire c'est
la victoire et qui est cet homme à
l'arrivée et du coup il se passe quoi il
va nous tondre peut-être qu est ce qui
fait qu teint fait une [ __ ] de
randonnée tout seul ou pourquoi lui et
pas le bouton qui a gagné la course
ils nous voient la vedette c'est notre
mouton qui est heureux comme ça qu'on
suivante s'il vous plaît lui ben et
alice blaster c'est cross
j'aime bien cette course je sens bien
les gens du peuple inconnu pour nous
propulser à base de canon on la connaît
ce parti allez olla hôpital une claque à
loutre lui demande qu'elle soit style
assez les canons l'animation on arrive à
destination aux mondiaux ship le mouton
veut son deuxième titre à on arrive au
sol oh mon dieu une attaque de rage hier
en [ __ ] c'est une technique pour pour
me retardé [ __ ] ça marche et salo
aller au front du maïs et du beurre il
ya bombardements d'avions sais pas
pourquoi est-ce que le train pour venir
me chercher c'est la fin bîmes
je passe tout à juba on va prendre
quelques le cougar a esquissé
d'intimider les autres avec son chapeau
piratés sont sous cachets y qui ne met
pas un cachet qui est transparente du
glc qui avait pas de musique ou à dubaï
pourrait mettre une musique de l'orissa
passerait bien aussi en vrai le cheval
devrait carrément je vous exposer et la
paroisse est que quoi
ouais c'est l'envol du cougar puis les
biens et les biens cela faisait quoi les
biens ci dessus ça se voit bien ice
cream nectarines aux dogues
bien sûr d'aller comment faire une
indigestion mais en moins de dix
secondes quoi la victoire pour nous en
arrière le style ou pas aulas il avait
comme des fusées mais non mais c'est
trop tard les amis ça suffit ça suffit
on va prendre le cheval keynes cavernes
arep du fait qu il convient poids la
seconde cheval c'est parti qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient et lui faisait poirier
a pas de problème mais quand même ce jeu
n'est pas mieux fait que nascar game un
peu moi je trouve que les collisions
sont bien faites voilà merci à game et
dans ce jeu il ya un petit un petit air
quand même non tu fais peur bravo tu
fais peur arrête toi c'est le saut
transformers transformers vote ma
nourriture au nom a il a pris le melon
panne on peut pas perdre on ne peut pas
faire comme mon dieu c'est vraiment un
obstacle impressionnant et le haut doubs
monde où l'on remonté en première place
on mange de la foulée au mégaphone a
déjà vu ça au moins 600 foire bah oui
parce que les hopper s'est pas fait
chier c'est ma victoire
loury peur témoigne
non non non pas monter non ce n'était
pas un bug in extremis on est premiers
malgré tout je suis content d'aller vous
n'êtes pas content en tout cas lui il
est pas content ça se voit lui fait la
gueule à avec son éventail sur la tête
on va prendre le bourg ce chapeau le
ballon est à moi je sais à dos et je
suis très gourmande
hier il a un peu déconné sur les
dimensions quand même nom est lui encore
plus tard mais il est glauque cet enfant
sans déconner c'est quoi cette boutique
oh non c'était un leurre ah là là ils
connaissent par coeur
regardez ils ont déjà couru avant bah
oui ça coupe vraiment eu sa coupe suis
désolé je sais que des fois j'ai un
délire avec ça mais là vraiment rien de
lui il se connaît à elles sont séparés
c'est le divorce a laissé hanoune
s'accouplaient maintenant regarder on
dirait qu'on joue des animaux empaillés
en fait sont pas envie sans payet
littéralement sur roulettes quoi en lui
c'est encore pire en le petit gros de la
course
il nous reste quand même monsieur rhino
un sas hébreu qui fait ça j'irai juste
une bande d'oiseaux affamés quoi
priscilla c'est à thouars yann moix
cette petite histoire manque c'est le
jeu attends moi je pense santander comme
ça toi vous un premier temps c'est
l'heure de la victoire
pardon mouche à c'est la première fois
je suis joueur le plus fort au monde sur
un jeu voilà on peut le dire un triomphe
rend à l'éventail est malgré tout en
course on compte sur toi
la pression est à son comble messieurs
dames oh mon dieu quelle cascade
est-ce qu'on retrouve pas les mêmes
éléments dont à peu près toutes les
courses
sincèrement mais est-ce que ça ce
n'était pas quelque chose et voilà c'est
la victoire à l'est et nous sommes les
grands champions aujourd'hui puisqu'on a
gagné toutes les courses d'acws sapin
fois que ça arrive il reste notre
créature parti sas à la fin de journée
après avoir couru ils vont tous faire la
fête c'est ça d'accord je pense y voit
la fête mais non qu'est ce que c'est que
ce délire voilà j'en suis bien reposé
sur ce registre si vous aura plu c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas bientôt sa faveur
au plaisir je crois qu'on a franchi
vraiment un nouveau stade dans le jeu
what the funk comme d'habitude on se
retrouve très vite dans une nouvelle
vidéo je pense sur un jeu qui sera un
peu plus évoluée celui ci puisque sinon
vrac on joue sur un écran noir pour
faire pire hein ah oui c'est mieux chat
du christ voilà c'était le nil éditions